There's one last thing I would
like to teach you today,
and it's called Template Inheritance.
Now, we can make this quite complex, but
for our purposes we're just going to do
this simple thing that'll make
our templates much easier to use.
If you notice on a web page,
let's draw one.
Most web pages have a title and
a footer.
And then they have some
content in the middle.
This might be the page slash.
And then you might have another
page that looks identical.
Maybe this is the /about page.
It also has a title.
It also has a footer.
The same title and the same footer,
and has some different content.
When you generate in HTML, you don't
want to have to write the same title and
the same footer over and over again.
Just like in your code
when you use functions and
classes to better organize your code, so
you don't have to write the same
piece of code over and over again.
You can organize your
templates in the same way.
And that's what I want to
talk about right now.
You can use template inheritance.
So you can have one template
that includes the header,
and the footer and
then you can have a bunch of
subtemplates that redefine
the content in the middle.
So here's how we're going to
organize our code now.
So here's what we have
right now in our code.
We have shopping_list.html, and
we have fizzbuzz.html, and these files
don't have anything in common, but we
want to add a little title to this page.
We're going to make each of these
inherit from the base.html.
And we're going to make each of
these inherit from base.html, and
base.html's going to have
some common html that
these two templates will share to
make them match a little better.
And I'll just go ahead and
show you an example of how to do this.
So first thing I'm going to do is
I'm going to make a new filed called
base.html.
I'm going to go ahead and put in things
I want these files to have in common,
and I'm also going to do
a proper HTML document this time.
I saved it as base.html.
Now remember,
HTML documents start with a doc type and
then we have the html tag.
And then we have the head.
And within the head,
we can have the title.
And so,
both our pages will share this title.
Within html, we have body.
And now,
I'm going to add a new syntax here.
Okay so then we have our body, open and
close, and then we close our html.
This is basic structure
of an HTML document.
And it's what goes inside body
that makes the page unique.
And I wanted to change that title too,
while we're at it, but
let's just worry about the body.
In jinja, the syntax that we can
use will look something like this.
The syntax for creating a block, and
a block is something that will be
shared amongst templates, you just say,
{ % block, and
then you give the block a name.
In this case, we're going to call it
content, and then you can say endblock.
And we can make each of our
templates use this block of content.
So, let's show how we would use
this base.html in shopping_list.
Let's add some code to our body that
all of our templates are going to
have in common.
I'm going to add a little
header across the top.
Okay so if it's add a little title that
we're going to put across the top of our
page, it's just an h1, and
I gave it a little extra styling.
This is CSS.
We gave it a background color of ddd,
and a foreground color of 888.
This is kind of gray with a slightly
darker gray on top of it.
I got rid of it's margin and
I gave it a height of 50px.
Also I'm going to add
a little style to the body.
This will make it layout
a little bit nicer, margin: 0.
Okay, so let's go ahead and
use this template in our shopping_list.
The syntax for this is quite simple.
All we do is at the top of our
file we say extends "base.html".
This tells this template that we're
going to be a part of base.html.
Now let's see what
this does in practice.
Let me make sure everything is saved.
Nothing here has changed and
our main handler, we're still
rendering shopping_list.html.
Let's go to our front page.
Okay, it's still quite a mess here,
let's reload this.
Once I reload it, we can see that
the header that I wrote is here
with the kind of grey
on grey background.
But none of our content is here.
Let's look at the source for this.
Okay, we basically see this
is our base.html file, but
we're not seeing any of that content
because that was in that block content,
and we didn't overwrite that.
Let's go ahead and
take a look at our templates again.
This is our base.html.
This is basically what we were
seeing as the source in our browser.
But our shopping_list.html hasn't
actually filled in this content yet.
Let's see how we do that.
All you do is here,
you say block content.
And this line here, block and
then the name content,
matches this line here in base.html.
And I've put a closing one
at the bottom, endblock.
We save this file and
we go back to our browser.
Then when I reload this page,
we see all of our stuff done here now,
within our base.html template.
And when we view the source,
we can see we have the base.html header.
Then we can see we have our form
contents, here in the middle.
And then we can have down here, it's
hard to see because of the scrolling,
but the end of the base.html template.
So, that's pretty handy.
This allows us to separate the content
of our pages and the templates for
that content from
the surrounding content that
all of our other pages
might have in common.
And I use this a lot in this course,
especially during the blog and
some of the other things.